célibataire bien je voyais je suppose
mais vous vous êtes rencontrés commun
c'est une histoire plutôt marrante plus
tôt il y a quelques mois donc le 4 de ce
mois là j'ai fait sa connaissance à un
festival de musique bien et ça va très
bien accroché entre lui et moi et disons
qu'on a eu des relations
la semaine suivante c'est à dire le 11
de ce mois là au baptême du bébé de john
pour être précisés suite à une
consommation assez sérieuse talent comme
mark et moi on a eu le même genre de
relation et et c'est là où c'est drôle
hein je suppose
en conséquence de ces relations la forme
de vie qui en résulte et qui réside
actuellement dans mon ventre peut-être
en fait aussi bien de l'unc pelouse
encore il est sûrement préférable que je
ne parle pas trop
ok je peux prendre le relais tu là c'est
bon je gère mon dieu mon dieu je crois
que je suis là encore un peu trop 2
et nous accueillons qui aujourd'hui
bridget et voici djak voici marque au
charmant vous êtes nos deuxième parent
de même sexe n'ont en réalité absolument
pas nous aurons la chance d'accueillir
ce bébé notre bonheur sera complet
c'est vous la mère porteuse c'est exact
oui je ne suis là que pour aider ce
merveilleux couple à accomplir son rêve
marc est très stressé par tout ça c'est
très émouvant pour toi hein on abeilles
c'est moi contrôle micro oui t'as pas
congeler teaser par hasard ou non à mon
avis à l'heure qu'il est ils sont déjà
dur j'ai pensé qu'à ce week end il
faudrait absolument qu'on sorte et qu'on
se lance comme des malades dans les
paires alcoolisation un dangereux fléau
de notre société
une nouvelle loi est elle nécessaire jet
miranda je voulais déjà dit pas de
discussion perçu entre les bangs
nous allons recevoir le ministre des
affaires étrangères qui nous parlera de
la crise qui menace le moribond dit tu
peux toujours retenter les sites de
rencontres vote soit rejeté sur kinder
une demi heure plus tard je me faisais
un plan à trois avec le robot le prince
andrew représentant spécial pour
l'investissement une commerce peut pas
attendre que je viens d'écrire son
premier livre pour enfants
attention tout le monde
antenne dans 10 tu peux toujours
retenter les sites de rencontre si ce
soir j'étais sûr tinner 4 une demi heure
plus tard on sait ça à trois avec toi le
prince andrew vient d'écrire son premier
livre pour enfants tu l'as fait exprès
sérieusement ça fait cinquante arme puis
avec marc d'un besoin urgent s'envoyer
en l'air
salut toi
ça a duré six heures c'est quoi qui est
un spectacle de marionnettes ou tata
bridget et aller je sais quand même pas
grand chose de lui tu veux savoir quoi
il est canon et il a une très très jolie
marionnettes encore une juste avec le
parrain et la marraine 6 et non un petit
bisou sur le feront peut-être je voulais
parler du bébé pas question de revenir
en arrière et de refaire les mêmes
erreurs
je suis enceinte alors que je peux en
faire de nouvelles dont une s'est pas du
tout lequel de nous et le père il ya
bien une de ces deux dates qui doit
coller les deux dates cole en réalité
alors revenez me voir avec le père quand
vous saurez qui sait
pour le meilleur et pour le pire le
destin nous a réunis il suffit tout les
deux y en a marre j'étais à porter un t
bien chaud jeter a porté un jeu super
vite n b mais soit déchargé de sa vie je
déchargeais de ton téléphone tu veux que
ce soit qui le perd ça c'est rien du
tout elle est amoureuse de lui autrefois
je les fais de moi un jour peut-être
en duo jet tueuse énorme hu
elle a ses portes oui lequel de vous
donner le père c'est moi
je me demandais convient de faire on
aurait on est au complet
bingo